hey guys walking back the new rockstars
I'm Sam basher with a brand new MCU
rewatch breakdown fresh out of the oven
today I'm going to be talking about Thor
the dark world the second installment
the Thor franchise and oh boy did I not
really care for this movie but this
ain't a review this is an Easter egg
hunt let's check out all the awesome
nods and winks to Marvel Comics the MCU
and more quickie spoiler warning for the
movies of Thor comics the TV shows the
cartoons all this goes on and on let's
begin though with comic book Easter eggs
my fave kicking it off with the title
the dark world but specifically let's
start with Dark Elves they are from
Norse mythology kinda basically there's
a never-ending list of different types
of elves in Norse mythology so Marvel
kind of simplified it down to light and
dark elves lights are sometimes good
guys dark elves are usually the bad guys
in the dark world is actually around in
the nine realms of the world tree called
far too famous on the screen right there
I tried to sound it out when I wrote the
script but it didn't help me at all now
let's talk about our main dark elf
Malekith the accursed originally created
for the comics as the leader of the dark
elves and he first appeared in Thor
number 134 in March of 1987 now I just
want to note that his costume and makeup
are actually a mix of a couple of his
different looks his scar in his face
alludes to his newer look which I'm a
fan of but also the star on his armor is
not - one of the first comic book looks
appearances costumes what-have-you and
we talked about Malekith we got to talk
about his weapon the ether which we
found out eventually there's the reality
stone one of the many Infinity stones
you can watch one of our videos on the
Infinity stones to learn more about it
but quickie notes the ether is the
reality stone so can actually alter all
of reality and in this movie that means
reverting the universe back to the dark
ages but in the comics it's kind of like
a wishing stone or it can bend the laws
of physics it can really do anything
which is a bummer that it just becomes
goop that deletes things from the
universe actually fun fact the reason
why the ether is a liquid in this movie
is explained later on by Odin actually
Malekith chose to turn that stone into a
liquid for reasons questionmark that
happens a lot in this movie a lot of
question marks of why people are doing
things and why things are the way that
they are but not a review let's keep
going focusing on this opening fight we
see King Bor who's Odin's father in both
the comics and in myth
but in the comics he made his debut and
journey into mystery number 97 in
October of 1963 also there's a very fun
Easter egg to the fate of Bohr later in
this movie but I'll get to that a little
bit and also let's give a nod to one of
the coolest looking villains in the MCU
Algrim the strong slash curse it's kind
of the same character in the comics and
in the movie they're both played by Otto
Wally 'aka yock bhaji now algorithm--
the strong first appeared in Thor number
30 47 in September 1984 and almost
didn't make it through that but let's
keep going and curse appeared in secret
Wars 2 in October at 1985 they are the
same character but curse is way o P he's
very cool just like he is in this movie
now in the comics he is a dark elf but
his transformation is not exactly the
same although we do get some fun nods to
his comic book roots like that awesome
helmet that he wears in the lava look to
his skin which is actually not too
Algrim falling into a lava pit which he
ends up surviving he gets amnesia though
oh we got to comic book II let's move on
it's give a shout-out to this opening
Thor and the Warriors three fight scene
in vanaheim which is from Norse
mythology but I do want to point out the
enemies that Thor and his friends are
fighting are called the Marauders in the
script which actually in Marvel Comics
the Marauders are a group of mutant
villains but in this they're just a gang
of aliens from different worlds which is
fun and I guess it's kind of a cool nod
to the x-men and there is at least one
more fun not to the x-men but more on
that in a second now if you notice
closely you might see a couple aliens
you might recognize there's some
Chitauri hidden deep in that giant
battle but also some production
designers said that there are korbinites
in this gang which is pretty cool if you
guys don't remember from the other Thor
breakdown so we've done for trailers
Ragnarok and what-have-you korbinites
are actually the species that beta ray
bill comes from and beta ray bill is
another character from Marvel Comics who
can pick up Thor's hammer so cool
speaking of other Thor breakdowns we
actually get a nod to Korg in this movie
kind of sorta at least his race the
Cronin's actually this giant rock
monster right here it's actually not two
two different things both Korg who some
people at Marvel said that this was
actually cord which I'm glad it ended up
not being caused cork and Ragnarok is
amazing but also too the rock men of
Saturn who Thor fought and journey into
mystery number 83 then moving forward to
Odin and Thor having a little meeting
you see him motion to SIF as possibly
you know
having a future relationship which
actually is true in mythology Thor and
SIF end up getting married but not so
much in the comics then we're in a suit
ahead quite a bit to the eternal flame
now this is during Frigga z-- funeral
you can see it right there which does
play a pretty big role in Thor Ragnarok
but I think the thing you want to learn
most about is the blackboard in that a
mental hospital that Eric is writing all
his notes on because this bad boys got a
lot of Easter eggs and I could only find
a few but oh boy these are great first
up the fault this is actually a nod to
the war of Kings event in the comics The
Fault actually is a portal or a gateway
to the cancerverse
an entire dimension where death just
doesn't happen it's extinct no one can
die there which is pretty cool speaking
of other dimensions we see the
crossroads written then right down there
this is actually dimension that Doctor
Strange used to imprison the Hulk when
he was hulking out you know doing a rage
attack then down here you'll see Simon
sent which is a nod to Walt Simonson who
actually showed up in the first Thor
film he's also one of the most
influential people to Thor in Marvel
continuity he actually created beta ray
bill scourge we saw in Ragnarok in throg
which we'll never really seen these
movies it's a frog that has Thor's
powers is so cool then over here you'll
see the Nexus of all realities which is
another nod to Man Thing if you checked
out my Iron Man 3
breakdown you'll know that there's a
very important person from man-things
lore who's in that movie but Man Thing
in the comics is the protector of the
Nexus of all realities which is just
like the center point and the the
Gateway to the multiverse you can go
anywhere from there and Man Thing Pertex
said they're moving over here you'll see
the equation Kyle plus Yost equals x
this is a nod to Craig Kyle who
executive produced this movie and
Christopher Yost who helped write the
screenplay they also wrote for Marvel
Comics and created the character that
you all love x-23
you remember her from Logan so that's
what that X naught is see it's another
x-men nod how cool and the last little
Easter Egg I have from this is this
little number right here six one six is
a nod to the six one six universe or the
main Marvel Comics University whenever
you pick up a comic at the comic book
stand that's the university are going to
be reading now the movies don't take
place in the six one six universe but
this is a fun nod then moving forward to
here Thor and his team strategizing you
know their escape and you hear the
mention of the einer yarr which in Norse
mythology is the name for the souls of
the dead in Valhalla
but in this
just the name for the city's guard in
Asgard still very cool
and this leads us to our Bohr Easter egg
from earlier you'll notice when they're
flying that ship out of Asgard they
knock over a boar statue kind of like
right at the head and Loki you know
makes a jab at Thor for being a bad
pilot well in the comics Thor actually
kills boar in the past he's actually
tricked by Loki into doing it but this
seems like a fun little jab at that
there's a lot of fun jabs in this
speaking of jabs meaning violence let's
talk about that awesome fight between
Loki Thor Jane Malekith and the Dark
Elves and curses you know it's a big
fight on smiles all the time there it is
on the screen again you hear Loki say
right here see you at Hell muster which
is kind of fun because he's not meaning
a Chi double hockey sticks he means a
cheat single hockey stick hell is in the
Dominion that hella is in charge of
where all the dead go which is pretty
cool
moving forward to the convergence main
battle scene at the end of this movie if
you look at some of the portals you'll
see boring ocean views and then boring
forest views and then you'll see one
lava look in little portal and some
people online have said that you can see
cert there this looks to be the Dominion
that I'm not going to say it's written
on the screen right there this looks to
be his Dominion that he rules over and
some say you can see his shape there
then moving forward to the very end of
this film we get the reveal that Loki's
alive and he replaced Odin or something
we'll figure it out in Ragnarok this is
actually a nod to Loki's famous pose he
does
oh so many times in the comics then
moving to the first post-credit scene we
get a look at this cocoon right here
which is a nod to Adam warlocks cocoon
from the comics actually that was
confirmed by one of the heads at Marvel
but I guess like was retconned after the
post-credits scene in guardians galaxy
vol 2 but anyways in the comics Adam
warlock was created in a pod that's
where he was birthed from and whenever
he gets like mortally wounded or ends up
dying he ends up going back into a
cocoon to be reborn again we also meet
ten alerta Vaughn the collector for the
very first time this scene actually was
directed by James Gunn director of
guardians of the galaxy wiki overview
the collector is played by Benicio del
Toro and he first appeared in Avengers
number 28 in May of 1966 now when we get
to guardians the galaxy I'll dive into
him more but I do want to point out that
the pink alien that's helping him Carina
our Carina is actually a nod to possibly
Carina the name of the collectors
daughter in the comics who you thought
that was fun let's go ahead and kick off
with the end
see you Easter egg starting with the
second iteration of the Marvel logo it's
pretty dope I'm a big fan of this one
also just like in the first Thor film
this movie opens with Odin narrating
something that happened in the past and
has Guardian history oh they're moving
forward to the ethers hiding place I do
like to note that there's a fun little
detail of the Norse symbols of the
Bifrost on the ground around it so I'm
guessing they just kind of spun the
wheel and let it just teleport anywhere
what a dangerous dangerous way to hide
something do you want to point out when
we see Loki being you know grilled by
Odin Loki was actually not supposed to
be in this movie he wasn't originally
written into the script but after his
popularity exploded after Avengers he
was added into the movie then moving for
- Loki in his prison cell talking with
Frigga his mother there's actually a
deleted scene where he imagines himself
being crowned king of Asgard he's
holding me only er actually it would
have been my favorite sin in the movie
but it was cut so I'm moving forward we
get a nod to Odin's Ravens huginn Munn
and we actually saw them for the first
time in Avengers they were flying around
when Thor and Loki were having a meeting
wait a minute I found something that I
missed in my first Thor breakdown
they're actually in the coronation scene
of when Thor is almost crowned as king
they're sitting at the very top of
Odin's throne I can't even see them now
until I had to zoom in there's little
tiny Raven sitting on top right there
how cool is that then moving forward to
the dinner scene where Thor's being sad
about Jane he can't visit Jade why can't
he visit J he's so sad you hear Ray
Stevenson do another joke remember from
the first film the scene was drunk I
like it I know that's great let's take a
look at when Heimdall and Thor are
having a little chitchat if you look at
hime Dale's chest it looks like the soul
stones right there but a lot of people
have debunked that now let's focus on
the scene where Odin is basically giving
the backstory to all the Infinity stones
he mentions that these objects without
calling them Infinity stones were from
before the universe and the ether is one
of them in Malekith chose to keep it as
a fluid or turned it into a fluid it's
not very clear but that will be over
very soon let's keep the cool scenes
going with Rene Russo doing this awesome
takedown with the sword really sad that
she dies but she does get a very
beautiful Viking funeral with floating
orbs I want to point out this scene
right here is Odin sick is this hinting
to his death in the next few years maybe
in the next film or I mean we all
thought that maybe
Odin had died at the end of this film
maybe low-keyed killed him maybe this is
supposed to be a hint to that then I
just want to mention this awesome scene
where Loki turns into Captain America
it's fantastic and the way they actually
shot this was that Chris Evans was
impersonating Tom Hiddleston who was
doing an impersonation of Chris Evans as
Captain America oh that's tough then we
get Thor getting stabbed by Loki in the
stomach for the second freakin time at
least you stabbed an Avengers and he was
stabbed now how many stabs to the gut
can you take and speaking of repeating
things we get another hand cut off this
is the second hand cut off in the face
two of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
there moving forward again we see Thor
hanging up his hammer on a coat hanger
this is actually improved by Chris
Hemsworth but moving on I've been trying
to do my best about like you know not
pointing out my gripes with this movie
but Thor is getting hit by the reality
stone by the ether and it's not really
doing anything to him even though this
stuff is supposed to just delete the
entire universe Hey look the ice hound
from Thor 1 is back he even looks better
this time the CGI is not too bad then
moving forward we get another arm cut
off this time it's teleported off which
i think is pretty cool this it actually
was confirmed by Kevin Feige to be a nod
to Empire Strikes Back since this is
phase 2 or the sequel to phase 1 of
Marvel then moving forward to the first
post-credit scene I did want to point
out the next two Adam warlocks cocoon
you'll actually see one of the aliens
that shows up in the background of
guardians of the galaxy they're called a
Rayner it kinda has that little palette
right there in front of its face and I
did enjoy that Thor came back for Jane
at the end of the movie and you saw the
ice dog thing running around chasing
Birds
how fun is that but before I go today I
just want to point out a few pop culture
historical little nods and winks I found
in this movie first up I wanted to point
out that SIF is a badass Jamie Alexander
because during the production of this
movie she took a spill down some stairs
when she slipped a disc in a thoracic
spine and then she's like chipped 11 of
a vertebrae I'm just paraphrasing her
quote that she said and then she only
took a month off and came back and shot
the rest of the movie she's a badass and
I'm bummed that she didn't get any nod
whatsoever in Ragnarok because hey your
champ also worth pointing out when
Frigga dies you see here kind of D
materialize and float up which I imagine
that means that she's going to Val halis
and she died during battle to protect
Jane or Jane's hologram though she
deserves it and finally guys I need to
point out of
the Stanley came you know you see him in
the mental hospital he's the one who
says he lost his shoe he wants his shoe
back because Eric took it to explain how
the universes or the portals were
crashing together you guys probably
caught it it was a fun one oh we made it
guys I hope you enjoy let me know what
your favorite Easter Egg was or if I
missed any please let me know in the
comments down below or on twitter at
only stupid answers ink up the valves
from stupid make sure you like this
video comment down below share and
subscribe to make sure you check out all
of our other breakdowns we're doing a
walking dead breakdown so we got a bunch
of Black Panther breakdowns and this
whole series of MCU rewatch breakdowns
I'm a big fan of doing these on it seems
like you guys enjoy it so that makes me
happy again
I'm Sam basher I'll see you next time
[Music]